bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
d'un sujet extrêmement familier et
pourtant encore méconnu le vert le vert
c'est un matériau étonnant qu'on
retrouve tout autour de nous dans notre
quotidien mais qui est utilisé aussi
bien pour faire de l'art que des
produits de haute technologie et dans
cette vidéo on va se demander notamment
qu'est-ce que c'est vraiment le vert
[Musique]
pour comprendre ce qu'est le verre on va
commencer par regarder à quoi il
ressemble au niveau microscopique vous
savez qu'on distingue classiquement
trois principaux états de la matière les
solides les liquides et les gaz les
solides ont une disposition périodique
et régulière de leurs atomes on parle de
structures cristallines et cela leur
donne notamment leur rigidité de leur
côté les liquides ont un arrangement
complètement désordonné de leur molécule
celle-ci sont proches les unes des
autres comme dans un solide mais sans
organisation cristalline et c'est ce qui
fait qu'un liquide coule il n'est pas
rigide et il va donc prendre la forme de
son contenant
et enfin pour les gaz les atomes ou
molécules sont également distribués de
façon désordonnée mais en étant plus
éloigné les uns des autres avec beaucoup
moins d'interactions entre eux
alors à vue de nez le verre a plutôt
l'air d'un solide il est dur il est
rigide et pourtant quand on étudie sa
structure microscopique on peut se
rendre compte qu'il est en fait organisé
comme un liquide il n'a pas de
structures cristalline et l'arrangement
de ses constituants est totalement
désordonné les différents atomes sont
assez liés entre eux comme dans un
solide mais d'une façon qui ne présente
aucune régularité on dit parfois que le
verre est un solide amorphe c'est-à-dire
qu'au niveau macroscopique il a tout à
fait l'air d'un solide et se comporte
comme tel mais au niveau microscopique
il a une structure de liquide une autre
façon de le penser c'est de se dire que
le verre est comme un liquide qui serait
hyper hyper visqueux tellement visqueux
qu'il serait dur rigide et ne coule pas
ou pas de façon visible alors pourquoi
pas le vert serait donc une sorte d'état
intermédiaire de la matière à la fois un
peu solide à la fois un peu liquide
sauf qu'il y a un truc qui cloche avec
ce que je raconte vous savez que pour
faire du vert on fait essentiellement
fondre du sable alors en général pas que
du sable mais on y reviendra le sable
c'est principalement des grains de
quartz dont la formule est si au2 c'est
du dioxyde de silicium aussi appelé
silice or le quartz a une structure
cristalline qui est bien connue vous la
voyez ici on a les atomes de silicium et
les atomes d'oxygène il y a deux fois
plus d'oxygène que de silicium donc
c'est bien et SiO2 en moyenne et le
quartz c'est par conséquent insolite
cristallin bien comme il faut il rentre
parfaitement dans la définition d'un
solide la température de fusion du
quartz donc du sable c'est d'environ
1700 degrés Celsius mais c'est bizarre
si le verre s'est fait à partir de sable
fondu pourquoi à température ambiante le
verre serait un liquide même très
visqueux il devrait pas à température
ambiante on est très largement en
dessous de la température de fusion du
quartz donc le verre ça ne devrait pas
avoir une structure am orphe ça devrait
juste à nouveau être du quartz avec sa
structure cristalline qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé et bien pour le comprendre
il faut s'intéresser à comment on fait
du vert quel est son procédé de
fabrication
pour étudier ça on va rester pour
commencer dans le cas du sable pur donc
du quartz SiO2 imaginons qu'on le
chauffe assez bien au dessus de sa
température de fusion disons allez à
2500 degrés à cette température on aura
un vrai liquide et sa viscosité sera à
peu près celle d'un miel bien épais on
l'a dit en théorie quand on va refroidir
ce liquide en dessous de sa température
de fusion de 1700 degrés il devrait
cristalliser redevenir du quartz mais en
pratique ce phénomène de cristallisation
il n'est pas immédiat et plus le liquide
est visqueux plus la cristallisation va
être difficile et lente à s'effectuer si
on fait redescendre suffisamment vite la
température de notre quartz fondue il va
devenir de plus en plus visqueux sans
avoir le temps de commencer à
cristalliser il faut voir que la
viscosité d'un liquide de ce genre varie
énormément quand on baisse la
température
le graphique que je vous mets ici
représente une variation typique de
viscosité qu'on obtiendrait en fonction
de la température sur l'axe horizontal
donc la température en degrés Celsius et
sur l'axe vertical la viscosité l'unité
de viscosité c'est le Pascal seconde
mais notez bien que cet axe est en
échelle logarithmique
il se passe donc la chose suivante quand
on baisse en température la viscosité
augmente énormément quand on passe sous
la température de fusion en théorie la
cristallisation devrait commencer mais
en pratique le liquide est déjà
tellement visqueux que cela étouffe en
quelque sorte le phénomène de
cristallisation
en le refroidissant on a piégé notre
matériau dans un état liquide très
visqueux un état de solidamorphe et sa
vitesse de cristallisation maintenant
est quasi nulle il ne peut plus
cristalliser bien qu'il soit en dessous
de sa température de fusion et c'est ça
qui explique que quand on fait fondre du
sable du quartz et qu'on le refroidit
assez vite on ne retrouve pas du quartz
mais du verre vous connaissez peut-être
une autre situation où on peut avoir un
liquide qui ne devrait normalement pas
en être un ce qu'on appelle la surfusion
de l'eau
l'idée est la suivante si on refroidit
de l'eau à une température inférieure à
0°, vous le savez ça devient de la glace
c'est un phénomène de cristallisation et
pour l'eau il n'y a pas de problème de
viscosité qui l'empêcherait ou la
ralentirait mais pour que cette
cristallisation puisse démarrer il lui
faut tout de même un phénomène
déclencheur en généralement juste une
toute petite vibration où la simple
présence d'une petite impureté ou de sel
minéraux ça suffit et en pratique quand
on met de l'eau au congélateur et bien
elle cristallise toujours pour faire de
la glace mais si on s'y prend avec
délicatesse et de l'eau assez pure il
est techniquement possible de refroidir
de l'eau liquide en dessous de 0 degré
sans qu'elle ne gèle tout de suite
cette eau on dit alors qu'elle est en
surfusion il est possible de manipuler
cette eau en surfusion qui peut
conserver cet état liquide temporaire
mais il faut savoir qu'un simple choc ou
la présence d'une impureté va très vite
déclencher la cristallisation mais tant
que ça ne se produit pas l'eau en
surfusion reste donc dans un état
liquide contre principe elle ne devrait
pas avoir et donc c'est comme avec le
vert dans les deux cas on arrive à
préserver un état amorphe liquide même
si on se trouve en dessous de la
température de fusion et donc on dit
parfois aussi que le vert est en fait un
liquide en surfusion alors évidemment le
mécanisme qui explique cette surfusion
est différent dans les deux matériaux
pour l'eau en surfusion c'est l'absence
d'impureté qui empêche la
cristallisation et pour le vert c'est la
viscosité ce qui est pratique avec le
vert c'est que puisque la viscosité
ralentit ainsi la cristallisation on a
la possibilité de le travailler de lui
donner la forme qu'on veut avant de le
ramener à température ambiante et même
sans prendre trop de de précaution la
cristallisation est tellement lente
qu'en pratique on est quasi certain de
rester dans l'état amorphe alors si
c'est tellement facile et naturel de
rester dans cet état amorphel si c'est
tellement difficile de cristalliser
comment on peut expliquer que les
cristaux de quartz qui constituent le
sable puisse exister
et bien il faut se souvenir que
justement les roches se forment sur des
échelles de temps géologiques le
refroidissement du magma quand il se
produit à l'intérieur de la Terre peut
prendre des milliers voire des millions
d'années et un minéral comme le quartz
aura donc largement le temps de
cristalliser malgré la lenteur du
phénomène évidemment une situation où ça
n'est pas forcément le cas c'est quand
le magma se trouve refroidit très
rapidement à la surface et c'est ce qui
peut former des roches comme
l'obsidienne qui a une structure amorphe
et qui est donc une sorte de vers
naturel
en conclusion le verre peut donc être
décrit à la fois comme un solide amorphe
et un liquide en surfusion extrêmement
visqueux donc en principe le vert coule
mais il coule très très lentement
évidemment c'est tellement lent que
jamais vous ne verrez votre bouteille de
bière ou votre fenêtre se mettre à
couler sous vos yeux mais on raconte que
si on regarde des vitraux d'anciennes
églises qui ont donc parfois plusieurs
siècles on peut observer qu'ils sont
légèrement plus épais à la base du fait
de l'écoulement très lent du vert qui
les constitue
mais en fait cette histoire est
vraisemblablement une légende urbaine il
y a une publication assez argumentée à
ce sujet mais si vous aimez les méthodes
rapides on peut s'en convaincre avec un
petit calcul d'ordre de grandeur en
utilisant de l'analyse dimensionnelle
j'avais consacré un épisode à cette
technique et on trouve que la variation
d'épaisseur du verre du fait de son
écoulement devrait de l'ordre d'un
nanomètre en un milliard d'années donc
non ça ne peut pas expliquer la forme
des vitraux donc le verre est un liquide
très très très très visqueux mais jamais
à température ambiante on ne pourra le
voir s'épouler bien maintenant qu'on a
réglé son compte à cette légende je
voudrais revenir sur un sujet essentiel
que j'ai pour l'instant
intentionnellement laissé de côté la
composition du verre
jusqu'ici pour faire simple j'ai fait
comme si le verre c'était uniquement
fait à partir de sable donc du quartz
dont la formule est SiO2 mais en
pratique on ajoute toujours d'autres
ingrédients il y a deux motivations à
cela faciliter la fabrication et obtenir
des verres avec les propriétés qu'on
souhaite commençons par le procédé de
fabrication je vous ai dit que le quartz
fondait autour de 1700 degrés donc en
pratique si on veut faire fondre
confortablement du sable pur il faut
monter à des températures proches de
disons 2000 degrés Celsius ce qui n'est
pas du tout évident alors on peut le
faire ça s'appelle faire du vert de
silice mais c'est réservé à certaines
applications très spécifiques pour du
verre normal on va devoir trouver un
moyen de ne pas monter autant en
température et pour ça on ajoute à la
composition du vert ce qu'on appelle des
fondants par exemple le carbonate de
sodium Na2 CO3
sous l'effet de la chaleur ce minéral va
d'abord se décomposer et libérer du CO2
et l'oxyde de sodium Na2O qui reste va
permettre d'abaisser la température de
fusion de notre verre c'est à priori un
peu contre-intuitif comme mécanisme le
Na2O font vers 1100 degrés le SiO2 vers
1700 degrés si on les mélange et qu'on
chauffe le tout on pourrait s'attendre à
ce que les grains de N2O font à 1100° et
ceux de CO2 à 1700 degrés mais en
pratique il se produit des réactions
chimiques entre les deux ce qui a pour
effet d'abaisser la température de
fusion de l'ensemble et même à des
valeurs inférieures aux deux
températures de fusion
la valeur exacte de la température de
fusion du mélange va dépendre des
proportions des deux composants mais ce
sont des choses documentées dans ce
qu'on appelle un diagramme de phase
alors je vous détaille pas tout mais ce
diagramme nous montre l'état
thermodynamique du mélange en fonction
de la température et de la composition
ici on voit qu'avec un peu plus de 20%
de Na2O pour presque 80% de SiO2 la
température de fusion passera à moins de
1000 degrés ce qui est quand même
beaucoup plus simple à atteindre que les
1700 degrés du quartz pur le problème
c'est que l'ajout de N2O a aussi des
effets secondaires indésirables comme la
diminution de la stabilité thermique et
chimique du verre ce qui peut notamment
le rendre trop soluble dans l'eau ça
serait un peu gênant alors pour
compenser ça un autre oxyde que l'on
ajoute fréquemment c'est l'oxyde de
calcium CAO qui permet de corriger ses
problèmes et d'obtenir un verre plus
durable le trio SiO2 Na2O CAO c'est la
base de la plupart des vers usuels aussi
bien les bouteilles que les vitres des
bâtiments ou des voitures
un verre de ce genre qu'on appelle
silico sodocalcique a des propriétés qui
le rendent bien plus facile à travailler
que le quartz pur par comparaison vous
voyez ici la courbe de viscosité en
fonction de la température c'est un
verre qui va fondre autour de 1000
degrés et généralement on essaye de se
mettre autour de cette zone là pour le
travailler c'est là qu'il n'est ni trop
visqueux ni trop
historiquement un oxyde que l'on a
longtemps ajouté pour faciliter le
travail du verre c'est l'oxyde de plomb
PbO2 ce dernier a plusieurs avantages il
abaisse aussi la température de fusion
ainsi que la viscosité rendant plus
simple le travail du vert quand on veut
lui donner sa forme mais l'oxyde de
plomb a aussi un impact sur les
propriétés optiques du verre il augmente
son indice de réfraction ça le rend plus
brillant et avec des reflets plus
colorés du fait de la meilleure
séparation des couleurs dans la
dispersion de la lumière blanche ce
verre au plomb plus joli que le verre
normal on lui a donné dans le langage
courant une appellation un peu étrange
on appelle ça du cristal alors il y a
des raisons historiques à ça mais vous
comprenez que cette dénomination est
très perturbante pour un physicien dans
le langage courant on va dire de ce
matériau c'est du cristal pour
sous-entendre c'est pas du vert alors
que sur le plan physique c'est justement
aussi du verre et donc c'est précisément
pas un cristal alors à part ce que j'ai
déjà cité il y a tout un tas d'oxydes
que l'on peut utiliser en plus ou moins
grande quantité pour modifier les
propriétés du verre la lumine l’oxyde de
bord de magnésium etc et une des
propriétés que l'on modifie souvent dans
le verre c'est sa couleur certains
ions apportés par des oxydes spécifiques
comme les oxydes de fer ou de chrome
possèdent en effet des propriétés
d'absorption qui peuvent fortement
colorer le vert et c'est comme ça qu'on
va lui donner toutes les teintes que
l'on connaît par exemple pour les
bouteilles de bière ou de vin sinon on
peut même ajouter de l'oxyde d'uranium
et obtenir du vert fluorescent qu'on
appelle de l'ouraline parmi les autres
propriétés que l'on souhaite contrôler
j'en ai un peu parler il y a la
stabilité thermique ou chimique pour des
applications en verterie de laboratoire
ou des flacons de pharmacie on utilisera
par exemple l'oxyde de bord B2O3 qui
améliore son inertie chimique
une autre propriété bien connue que l'on
cherche à maîtriser c'est le coefficient
de dilatation la dilatation thermique
vous le savez peut-être c'est ce qui
fait qu'un matériau peut augmenter de
volume sous l'effet de la température et
c'est notamment ça qui cause les
ruptures par choc thermique si vous
versez de l'eau bouillante dans un verre
ordinaire la surface du verre sera
soumise d'un coup à une certaine
dilatation tandis que l'intérieur ne
chauffe pas tout de suite et donc ne se
dilate pas autant et cela crée des
contraintes dans le verre qui peuvent
provoquer son éclatement vous l'avez
peut-être déjà vécu c'est une rupture
par choc thermique pour limiter ce
phénomène on peut essayer d'abaisser le
coefficient de dilatation du verre et
c'est le principe du ver dit pyrex dont
la composition lui permet d'avoir un
coefficient de dilatation 2 à 3 fois
plus petit que celui du verre ordinaire
et donc de bien mieux résister aux chocs
thermiques
mais il existe deux autres applications
encore plus exigeantes pour lesquelles
on essaye de se débarrasser des effets
de la dilatation thermique les miroirs
des télescopes et les plaques de cuisson
les miroirs des télescopes c'est pour
des raisons de stabilité de l'image on
ne veut pas que les images soient floues
à cause de légères variations de
température qui déformeraient le vert
pour les plaques de cuisson c'est plutôt
pour éviter que la plaque ne suspect
naturellement à force de chauffer de se
refroidir plusieurs fois par jour pour
ces deux applications on aimerait
idéalement un verre avec un coefficient
de dilatation de 0 ou du moins aussi
faible que possible mais ça c'est
impossible à faire avec du vert
sauf en ayant recours à une idée géniale
la vitrocéramique
[Musique]
alors dans le langage courant le terme
vitrocéramique a fini par désigner un
type de plaque de cuisson et en fait il
s'agit au départ du nom du matériau très
spécial qui est utilisé pour faire ses
plaques ces plaques qui extérieurement
ont l'air d'être en vert l'idée de la
vitrocéramique c'est de partir d'un
verre donc ayant une structure amorphe
et de forcer en son sein l'apparition de
micro cristaux grâce à un traitement
thermique particulier
une vitrocéramique c'est donc une
matrice de verre amorphe qui emprisonne
une certaine proportion de microcristo
d'où le terme vitro céramique et le truc
génial c'est qu'en choisissant une
composition bien spécifique on peut
créer des micro cristaux ayant un
coefficient de dilatation négatif alors
c'est assez rare comme phénomène mais on
connaît un certain nombre de cristaux
qui dans une certaine plage de
température font l'inverse de la plupart
des matériaux il se contracte sous
l'effet de la température c'est
notamment le cas de certains cristaux
obtenus à partir d'un mélange d'oxyde de
lithium d'alumine et de silice et donc
l'idée géniale c'est de partir d'un
verre contenant notamment ses oxydes et
de faire apparaître ces micro cristaux
dans les bonnes proportions on obtient
alors un matériau composite ou le
coefficient de dilatation positif de la
matrice verrière est plus ou moins
exactement compensée par le coefficient
de dilatation négatif des cristaux et
donc au total cette vitrocéramique aura
un coefficient de dilatation quasiment
nul
alors il y a encore plein de choses
qu'on pourrait raconter sur le vert et
sur ces dérivés et notamment les vers
réalisés avec des oxydes de beaucoup
plus exotiques que la silice SI2 par
exemple les Verts à base d'oxyde de
germanium ou de phosphate sachez aussi
que certains micro-organismes sont
capables de créer du verre de la silice
amorphe mais en utilisant un procédé
chimique donc sans avoir à chauffer à
2000 degrés c'est notamment le cas des
dix atomes ces micro-organismes marins
qui ont la capacité de se fabriquer une
minuscule coquille en silice amorphe en
plus c'est très joli
mais le principe du verre celui d'un
liquide en surfusion très visqueux et
bien ça ne s'applique pas seulement aux
oxydes minéraux par exemple on peut
aussi faire des verres métalliques on
refroidit très rapidement du métal fondu
et on le piège dans une structure
amorphe faut juste refroidir vraiment
très vite parce que contrairement ouvert
le métal lui ne demande qu'à
cristalliser
et en laboratoire on sait même faire un
truc incroyable on sait faire des verres
d'eau des verres d'eau non pas des
verres d'eau de l'eau solide amorphe
mais pour ça il faut vraiment refroidir
très très vite du genre arriver à faire
passer une goutte d'eau à moins 100
degrés en une minute seconde alors oui
c'est assez compliqué mais bon c'est
pour la science c'est pas pour refroidir
votre pastis voilà c'est tout pour
aujourd'hui je vous laisse à la
contemplation de vos glaçons de vos
bouteilles de bière et de vos plaques de
cuisson rendez-vous sur le discord de
science étonnante pour prolonger la
discussion le lien est comme toujours en
description et puis moi je vous dis à
très vite pour une nouvelle vidéo à
bientôt